adam you had a goal to make a feature
film before a certain age yeah
wanna tell us about that absolutely yeah
um
so back in the day i've been trying to
be a filmmaker since i was like
17 like in earnest it's like this is
what i'm gonna do
um but i always thought it was gonna be
like robert rodriguez
you know like he was my idol you know
like young gun like
doing his feature by 23 i was like
that's gonna be me i definitely have
that talent
then 23 came and 23 went
and i hadn't done it i was like okay all
right like maybe
maybe i'm not like robert rodriguez
maybe i'm more like
i don't know quentin tarantino he did
his bite like 27 his first feature
i'll do that 27 comes 27 goes
um and i was i was sort of devastated
you know because i was working on a lot
of projects and doing a lot of shorts
but uh i i hadn't gotten it done and
it hit me when i turned to 30. i was
like that
that's like a big milestone when you
turn 30 you know like
you start thinking about a lot of things
you know like your body starts changing
you you get like weird like you know
like aches in your knees or whatever
like it just it just happens at 30. try
so i was like all right i i have to do
it you know
like i'm 30 i wanted to do it by at
least 30 and now i'm 30. like
how do i do it before i become 31
and i was going through you know all of
this at the beginning of the year
like january of i think it was uh 2015
and i was like okay i turned 31 in july
of 2015. how do i do a feature
by debt you know and i had this idea um
it was like a very small contained one
room thing and i was like okay i can do
that like i can do that quickly
um and so i just sort of
set my mind to it set a date and i was
like i have to do it you know like
july was that point where i was like i
have to at least shoot it by then
so i just went for it in january i
started writing the script
wrote the heck out of it um you know in
february i started doing revisions to
the script while just going
right into pre-production it was the
sort of thing was like i don't have time
to look for funding
and do that whole light game because
that's a whole nother job
that i just didn't have time for so i
was like all right i will find a way to
fund this it'll be
super super cheap i'll have to put a
bunch on credit cards do the old like
kevin smith clerks method
um and just pay for it that way because
i have to get it done
and you know i just started reaching out
to people compiling the cast and the
crew and like
i found that you know there's a certain
point in projects
where it does sort of start moving like
it's this big boulder and you've been
pushing it or it's like this train on a
track and you've been pushing it
and then the train starts moving on its
own and then you realize like oh
this this is happening like people are
into it people like
the project they want to be involved
like things
doors start opening for you strangely
you know like the universe
helps you out a little bit um and that's
what i found for that
which was amazing because i was like all
right this is supposed to happen
so let's get it done and then uh
everything sort of worked out and we
found a great location
and we shot it in four days in june
like a full month before that before my
birthday before that cut off day
and uh and we did it you know and
looking back it's tough to you know
sort of pick apart exactly like how it
all came together
but but it did so i i think the central
driving thing was that
i had a date where i had to get it done
and i just found a way to make it work
well let's backtrack a second because i
know you had this
goal and you felt like the clock was
ticking but it wasn't like you were just
couch surfing and
going to raves all the time you had a
job
you were paying before that and then you
had gone to college so
you were doing many other things that
essentially would tire a lot of people
out sure yeah absolutely i mean
uh while i was doing that i had this
full-time job
um and it was that thing
where i think back when i was trying to
be like that
robert rodriguez like 23 year old now
that i'm like
far past that i go you know what i
actually wasn't ready
and i would hate to have seen what my 23
year old
feature film would have been because
i've seen some of my 23 year old short
films
and i'm super embarrassed by him you
know what i mean so to try to put that
all together in a feature i don't think
mentally i was ready yet and i don't
think
that from like getting your 10 000 hours
in
in terms of like the reps in terms of
writing and directing like getting all
those hours in
so you can actually make something that
i would think to be
worthwhile for myself i hadn't done that
yet i hadn't gotten the reps in
you know so i needed to just keep
writing and and failing and making
shorts and having them not turn out well
and making pilots for web series
that never went anywhere and just making
all this stuff because
in the making stuff and in the writing
stuff and in the failing
and in all those rejections that's you
know where you really learn
how to make a story and craft a story
and so i think by the time i turned 30
i had done enough where i was
i was ready to do a feature you know i
knew that i could do it
i had done some you know fairly decently
larger scale
shorts and i'm like you know what i can
do
i can do a feature too looking back do
you think that there are like
two schools of filmmakers there's two
schools of filmmakers there's
one that's sort of this rock star type
they can just take these risks
and luckily everything turns out but
then there's others that
plan things more and maybe that's just
their style and it doesn't mean
they're any less of a filmmaker but they
feel better
knowing that eyes are dotted t's are
crossed sure i mean there's there's
definitely
part of that i think um i think
a lot of it can be like some people are
just sort of
those like young savants you know and
some people are sort of right for their
time
you know like um would el mariachi you
know
have was it made in 2019
would anybody care you know what i mean
versus when it was made in 92 93
when the indie landscape was so
different you know
and that's that's something to think
about too like there's a lot of like
luck in the time and luck in the place
um
but in terms of like you know people who
are you know potentially more
pragmatic or like to dot the eyes and
cross the t's and
versus the more rock stars i mean part
of that is probably
you know just who you are as a person
and what you're gifted with
and i thought that i was a gifted young
auteur and i realized that i was
not i realized that i needed to really
put in the work
and you know build up that confidence
build up you know the ability to tell a
story
like and that's when i sort of
appreciated the stories about you know
like
like jc shandor you know who was like 37
when he got his first you know big film
you know and he had been working for a
while
he thought he was gonna quit and that's
like and it worked out for him because
he just kept going and
those are the stories that i really you
know are that i'm drawn to now
and those are the stories that i feel
are very under reported
you know by hollywood because everybody
likes the 23 year old
you know who does something splashy and
big and it's like
you know kid you have not lived long
enough to really
understand how to tell like a story you
know and there's some people i'm sure
that have
but a lot of times you know they're just
riffing off of movies and
because that's all the experience that
they had i know that that's the case for
me is like i didn't have enough of life
life experience i was just like oh i
like tarantino's movie so i'm going to
make a version of that
you know and it's all about like trying
to find your own identity in that regard
but for me
i needed you know to just
take the time and just work a lot
and fail a lot in order to
get to a spot you know where i can make
that first feature
right and maybe not everybody's meant
for the lifestyle of what did
rodriguez do like this medical testing
and these different things to raise
money i mean
and that's very like whoa when you hear
the story that's but again not everybody
and maybe i shouldn't have used the word
rock star because than that but
that sort of like carefree rebellious
and some
other people might be more planners yeah
and it doesn't mean they're any less
talented it's just it's a sexier sell
when you
think yeah i put everything on a credit
card yeah and luckily it worked out
don't try this at home kids but you know
yeah and that's the thing the
interesting thing
you know like when you hear about like
the real stories behind it you figure
out like oh well rodriguez
even though he was 23 he had been doing
this for so long and he had made
hundreds of short films by the time he
made his feature at 23.
and i had certainly not you know so it's
a little bit
unfair to judge in that regard because
like what took
me 10 years you know it took him 10
years but he was starting
you know when he was like 10 or 11 or
whatever was able to get all those films
in
you know so he was ready by the time you
know he hit 23 obviously
and also too some people are just risk
takers yeah by nature
do you think you're a risk taker or
you're more of a planner
that's a good question um i uh
i think i'm kind of both
i l i like to plan and i like to
you know make sure that everything's
sort of ready but
like you do have to take risks
a lot um you know you want to sort of
have the universe try to show you
the way a little bit but if it doesn't
you still have to have the courage
to make you know that leap take that
risk
why do you think it's so important for
so many filmmakers
to make that first feature film by 30.
that's a fantastic question
um by
30 uh i i think it's you know your 20s
are about
sort of figuring out who you are and a
lot of trial and error and a lot of like
messing up and
when you hit your 30s you sort of have
that feeling like you have to have it
all together
right like you're an adult now you're an
official adult
you're not in the 20s like put all that
you know childish stuff behind
you're in the 30s you're you're thinking
about building a family and and
doing all of that and you're really
thinking about your career and
and sort of you know how you advance in
that whatever it may be
day job you know we're filmmaking um
and so i think it's that that pressure
of of turning 30 and
feeling like you need to become a full
adult
that pushes people to go well i need to
do a feature now
um and i think you know you know some
people may be ready for that just as
developmentally some people you know are
still going to be
tooling around and you know doing all
this club life and dating and stuff in
their thirties which you know
you can do or should do or have to do
you know depending on your situation
or situations yeah but they could be in
their 60s doing that
exactly yeah it really just does depend
on the person
yeah i think a lot of it well it seems
like it comes from family pressure
or that traditional sort of idea and
people don't want to let their
their family unit down and some people
don't have that and they have a
like maybe they wish they had it because
they're so carefree
yeah so i think there's two two sides of
the coin and i've seen a lot of people
that
come from very close-knit families where
you know they really want their kids to
succeed
yeah but then there is that pressure
like you've got to grow up by 30.
sure so i think when you're creative it
might be
tricky because you want to please the
people that you love but at the same
time
you're still an artist in some way and
yeah do that
so you've managed to do both you've done
a lot of short films you've made a
feature
and you said that you were paying
for sometimes you know you would like 15
hour days
yes back when i first moved out to los
angeles
i i didn't go to film school um i went
to a journalism school in des moines
iowa where i
was a part of the radio and tv
production program so i learned a lot
technically
you know but what i didn't learn was how
to like make films
or how to tell stories you know um
in that regard so what i knew that i
needed once i moved out to la was like
real on-set experience like how is a
movie set run
what makes you know a good movie set
what makes a bad movie set
in terms of operating it because if i'm
going to be running this one day
i need to know what styles of work i
like
what styles of work i don't and when you
start at the very bottom
and you sort of see everything from that
low position
and you see how like people are are
treated and you know you have those eyes
into everything
i think it's a really good look and it
was for me
about like how i want my sets to run
and the one set that i worked on
which really set a high example of like
what an amazing film set
is is uh when i worked on a serious man
the coen brothers movie great yeah it
was uh it was filming back in minnesota
and i was like this is an amazing
opportunity i will
uh i got to get on this set right so i
found a way to connect to the ads and i
told them i was like
like i know you may need pas from out
there i will i'm from there i'm from
minnesota i will move back there
for you know while it's being shot you
don't have to put me up you don't have
to do anything like
just let me work on a coen brothers set
yeah and
they're like cool come on board so i did
it
uh i spent a month out there and
just being able to like see how the
cohen's worked
and just i mean seeing roger deakins
work for one was just
amazing but um being able to
to see how respectful everybody was
how nobody yelled how quiet the set was
um how everybody did their jobs and like
was very it was a very you know familial
feeling set um it was really
just eye-opening because you've been you
know i at least have been
on those sets of low budget things and
like hallmark movies and
big movies you know all in between in tv
shows and you
you see like the tensions and the stress
and the yelling and the screaming and
the disrespect like you see
all of that um and the cohen's like on a
serious man they had
none of that like it was the smoothest
running set
um everybody was really on board and it
was it was a pleasure to be on
how cool yeah so sorry you were in la
and then you thought well let me go back
please
please let me be on the set and you went
back home 100
i mean like there was no other way i was
going to be able to get on that set it's
like
i had to sacrifice i had to be like you
know i will fly myself out there i'll
stay at my parents house
it'll be fun to see everybody again you
know but just
let me work on this movie please and so
did you stay
at your parents house i did yeah yeah so
what time would you leave to go to set
that's so
oh man i would i would leave i would say
around like 5 a.m
to get to set around like 5 30 6 because
the pas are like the first on set
you know first on set last to leave um
so yeah you know just sort of driving
through the night and getting to
whatever location whether it's you know
the suburban street that the family
lived on
or you know the park where they're down
by the lake like
it was it was fun you know and allowed
me to see
a different part of minnesota and the
place that i grew up
than i would have otherwise and you know
you realize like oh yeah there's this
whole
strip of a neighborhood that has you
know houses that were just
still they lit still look like they're
from like that era you know like the 60s
the 70s like
it's really trippy and it really opens
your eyes about like what is around
you know what's available sort of you
know in your hometown
and how was it to see the actors between
takes because that's where like
the first i think the first set i was on
was melrose place
back i mean like well aren't there two
of them they're the first one the 90s
one
yeah and for me seeing like what it was
actually like
seeing them turn the camera okay let's
try another angle how was that for you
um it was cool when i could see it you
know because as a pa
sometimes you don't necessarily get to
be like that close to set
sometimes you're stuck way out you know
like blocking traffic or making sure
you know that people don't you know
invade the set or whatever but when
i got to sort of see uh you know like
some of the
smaller scenes you know with the actors
it was it was really cool to see
you know how how excited everybody was
to be there and
like how the cohen's worked with
everybody and you know how
easy it sort of seemed that's that's
what was interesting is like
for me working with actors especially
established actors
you know as somebody who hasn't you know
done that many films
it's uh it's a little you know
freaky you know you're like you've done
a lot and what have i done
so it's a little intimidating and uh
but they made it seem so easy which is
like that's sort of what i want to
strive for
so when you wrapped how was it you you
had to fly back to la
yeah yeah yeah so i spent about a month
um
home and then my time was done i was
like all right well back to la to try to
find the next job you know
because that's what it is when you're a
pa it's like it's making those
connections on set
and trying to get work and like pinging
those connections when you're out of
work and
trying to figure out what to do so it's
it's a really terrifying thing um that i
i'm glad i did when i was young and i
sort of didn't know any better
and i was just full of this head of
steam of like all right like i'm gonna
make this happen no matter what
and you just sort of because you're
fearless in that regard you know even
though you're full of
fear which is an interesting dichotomy
like you're just going for it because
you have to survive one like survival
instincts are
in and you know very active because
you got to make rent you got to be able
to eat you know
so getting that work you know is sort of
a you know life or death
type thing did your filmmaking career
begin when you were in high school
i wouldn't necessarily call it like a
filmmaking
career um but it was definitely
me sort of dipping my toe into
the visual arts i guess and and telling
stories
on screen i was very very motivated
and excited by the show jackass
back in the day um so when i was you
know like a
sophomore and junior and senior my
friends wanna and i would go out
and uh just do our own video you know
like oh let's do stunts let's do stupid
stuff let's jump in the bushes and do
all that
um and we sort of incorporated that when
i was in the video production course in
my senior year
we incorporated that you know into the
morning announcements
so it was me and my buddy ken we had the
show called
adam and ken out on the town and we
decided to take the morning
announcements for every friday
just out into circle pines minnesota
um and instead of you know having them
just in the studio every day
so we decided to just be creative and
see what we can get away with
go out like talk to people get random
people to read the announcements
film funny skits have funny stuff going
on in the background
and uh the the teacher sort of let it
happen
which was amazing because we were doing
you know like crazy weird stuff
um but people really you know the kids
they
loved it you know and that was the first
time
that i was like i like doing this i like
being on camera and i like performing
and i like
coming up with creative concepts and
executing them
and uh you know it helped that you know
we were looked at as sort of like
super popular you know like walking
around like oh it's adam and ken look at
them and you know being like
a nerd and a band nerd you know like
having that sort of notoriety senior
year was kind of fun
so you know obviously that sort of pumps
up your confidence
and made me go like all right maybe this
is something that i can do so that's
what
what took me to drake university um
is that like all right let me do like
radio and tv production because like
maybe i want to have a radio show or
maybe i want to be
an on-camera personality what exactly do
i want to do do i want to get into news
maybe i don't know
um so i went to drake got into the
journalism program
and very quickly realized that uh i was
not cut out for news
because i had an assignment to like go
and shoot like a news story
and i went out and i was like all right
cool like i can shoot all this great
stuff
report on this thing and i come back
with the footage
and we edited it together and the
producers of the show were like oh we
can't use this
like none of this footage is usable
because you're like you're
taking the camera and you're walking
through trees and you're doing all this
like
artsy stuff like that's not news like we
need you to put a tripod down
and then pan it from left to right you
know watching students walk across the
campus like that
for news you know getting b-roll that's
what it's all about and i
was that was so not my taste
but it was great having them go like no
thank you
they made me go okay well maybe that's
not like
for me you know like news is not for me
so
you know maybe maybe film or something
more creative is is uh what's for me
so i think it was uh my
sophomore year where drake who doesn't
have a film program or didn't at the
time
uh decided to have their very own uh
film festival
and i was like well that's cool like my
buddies and i
because we were you know freshman year
shooting more jackass videos and we
decided to make a little
you know like business out of it so we
would make like an hour-long compilation
of videos
and then uh we made a dvd of it designed
the box like got the discs made did all
that and started selling it on campus
like
had her own little you know side hustle
um
we decided sophomore year to go ahead
and like just shoot like an actual
narrative
um so i wrote it i directed it
it was like a small five minute black
and white thing
and i remember shooting it i remember
the exact spot that i was at
we were in this like hallway in the
basement of of the residence hall that
we were at
and i remember after getting one take
and having like a full day of doing this
behind me going like this
this is amazing like this feeling that
i'm feeling
like i can't replicate it i've never
felt it before like i
need this in my life because if this is
how i feel making a movie
like there's no better feeling there's
nothing else i can do nothing else will
compare and nothing else has and that's
why
since that time you know i had
first just went into it like i need
to make films because it makes me feel
something that i
can't even really describe but it makes
me
feel like the most pure version of
myself
like that's the best part is is knowing
that when i'm on set
when i'm shooting when i'm working with
actors working with crew
making something i never feel better i
never feel more like myself
and to be able to be yourself fully
is a gift that i don't know if a lot of
people have
or get to have and i wish everybody
would have that
but filmmaking is is that for me so
that's why i keep doing it and that's
why i'm in love with it and that's why
that's what drives me every day
at what point when you were at drake
university did you know you were going
to come to la
oh yeah um so that's a good question
um i think i was thinking about
dropping out in freshman year because
like
i i sort of you know i kind of got that
bug about like well maybe maybe this is
not the right place for me and i had
this advisor uh todd evans who was great
and he convinced me like just stay in it
you know just just keep doing it like
you'll learn a lot here it may not be a
film school
but in this program you'll really learn
a lot and so i did
i stuck into it and i'm happy that i did
um
because it really allowed me when
i was in my senior year to go ahead
and take the chance to like
get an internship in los angeles and my
dad knew somebody knew somebody who
lived out here and had access to the uta
job list i have no idea if that's still
a thing
but it was full of like jobs and
internships and everything and so i just
started submitting internships
like mad like get me out there for a
summer i need a summer internship
i need to know if los angeles is right
for me
you know because there were a couple
other places that were filmmaker
friendly i think
austin was a place that i was thinking
about
doing it in minnesota wasn't a thing
like back in the day
yeah there were there wasn't really a
lot of people doing film in minnesota i
think that has changed
because i met a lot of people out of
here out here that are from minnesota
and so it seems like filmmaking is sort
of catching on which is fantastic
um but it was it was getting an
internship and landing that
um you know in that summer the summer of
2006 it was
uh that i was able to come out and uh
you know it was a terrifying thing to do
you know for me
going from minnesota you know like
generally a smaller town i didn't live
in
the twin cities i lived you know in a
suburb like 20 minutes
north and uh you know like you
you come to l.a and you're on the 10.
and i remember going like where's the
hollywood sign
and i was looking to my right because i
saw the mountains i was like where's the
hollywood sign
and in classic this is what happens when
you first come to la story
i look forward and traffic had stopped
and i rear-ended somebody
oh my goodness yeah and it wasn't a bad
rear ending it was just a bump
but that was my introduction to la is
getting into traffic on the 10 and rear
ending somebody
which everybody should have and i'm sure
so many people do
but um but yeah after that you know and
sort of getting my bearings
in la um i very quickly found over the
summer that like
the town was for me you know like it
it fit my vibe it was full of people who
were like
me you know who are passionate about
film passion about entertainment
you know interesting creative artsy
hard workers you know and so diverse
and that's that's the one thing that i
learned about like being on set
is that like you meet so many different
people from so many walks of life
you know from like the craftsman you
know in the art department to the grips
you know to the camera people like those
are all very different
people you know different types of
people want to be grips
versus want to be camera nerds versus
you know or set decorators or costumers
or
you know the ads like it's it's a lot of
different people but
it's great and how all of those
disparate personalities sort of come
together
and like make something that can be
transcendent
like that is is kind of the beauty of
making films
so it's 2006 you're driving around
you're you're feeling good
you know wind in your hair and then the
recession hits
yeah and what happens then yeah so
um i had been doing pa work
um you know going from various project
to various project big projects to small
projects an unpaid project to semi-paid
projects and stuff like that
and i remember it was around the
recession and the writers strike
and i had just done a stint as a
director's assistant on indie feature
which was super fun and i learned a lot
and i was doing reality tv which i never
thought that i would do but
like somebody offered me a gig and when
you need a gig you take a gig
um so i was a driver um before one of
these reality shows shot over in west
hollywood you know
driving people from parking up into the
mansion in the hills oh that's great
um so it was it was a trip um
but i i realized like it was around
christmas time
i was sitting in this van pretty much
all day i was getting fat
you know and i was i the biggest thing
is that i
wasn't able to
[Music]
to write or even direct that was i mean
directing was like
i can't afford that you know what i mean
like so i had to at least write but i
couldn't even do that
because you know you're working five or
six days a week sometimes even seven
and it's at least 12 hours you're
definitely working
you know 14 sometimes 16 you know it's
long and you just come home exhausted
and i found that it sapped any sort of
creative
drive that i had in me and i hated that
because i was here to make stuff
i wasn't making stuff so i had to
you know really think about it and go do
i want to keep
doing this you know i'm sitting
at the top of this parking structure in
west hollywood in this passenger van
getting fat being unhappy like
i need something that's going to help me
get
to that goal of writing and directing
full-time
and that was an office job that's what i
figured out it's like you know what i
need the structure
i need the five-day work week i need
nine to five
nine to six but i need nights i need
weekends
so that i can do what i wanna do um and
i was able to find that i reconnected
with um a buddy that i met at the
internship
and uh he was like hey just so happens
that
there's a receptionist spot open like do
you want that
i was like you know what yeah you know i
was
man maybe 25 at the time you know like
two or three years doing pa stuff and it
was
it mentally it was like okay this is
definitely starting over
it's starting at the bottom it's a
receptionist you know there's no
there's no uh you know guarantee that
it'll lead to anything but i was like
you know what like i will do it and
that's one of those risks
that i was like i have to take you know
i have to take that risk
i will start from the bottom
again if i need to in order to make it
that i can shoot and write and and have
that time so
i took the plunge um and it worked out
and for me
getting an office job was what i needed
to get my creative flow going
and and to keep it going which is
interesting because you would think
doing the same thing or having you know
that set schedule
every day like wouldn't that make you
you know not as
creative or you know if life was
monotonous you know
would it uh but i found that uh that i
needed that and helped me you know when
i came home like
i could write and like you know i was
much more creative
i find that so interesting that at 25
you knew you needed structure
that's really that's really interesting
to me yeah
but before you thought it was going to
be more of this like free-for-all
cool i'm going to be making movies and
then you realize oh wait a minute i need
some type of discipline
in order to be freer and creative
yeah that's really interesting i mean
because the thing that i found
was that when you're constantly looking
for work
and trying to survive that's where your
brain power goes
you know you need to find that next job
you need to pay rent you need to eat
that doesn't really leave a lot of time
for like what's this amazing short film
concept or what's this feature i could
do
you know so it's a lot of hustling and
for me
it was hard to fit in you know a lot of
the creative
stuff when i was sort of struggling to
survive so it really was
a let me just get an office job that
will pay me and i
don't have to worry about that then and
that way
more brain power is freed up so then i
can concentrate on
you know what creative ideas do i have
how do i make this
fascinating and so since then how many
films have you made shorts or features
included yeah yeah um i've written a lot
more
than i've shot because shooting in la is
expensive
that's just the fact of life because you
want to pay people
you know crew members a decent wage
like i feel like terrible and i couldn't
make people like
work for nothing you know i mean that's
that's after working for nothing it's
really hard for me to go like hey please
work for nothing because i know
i know what that's like um so it's very
expensive
um to shoot stuff so i haven't shot a
ton of things
um but i have written an enormous amount
of things
um and that was all in the service of
getting those
10 000 hours in so you know it was
it was breaking you know stories with my
writing partner will
about this like sci-fi web series and we
did that for a while
and that helped us figure out like how
to make worlds
you know because everything started to
turn to
a more like franchise model and a world
building model
in terms of hollywood um so that was
very helpful for us
you know and it's learnings that we've
used when we've gone to create you know
tv shows um
it's like how do you create a world and
how do you do that um
so yeah yeah i've written a bunch
written a bunch of features um
sorry yeah you crowdfunded over 30 grand
yes
pretty amazing so you know there was
stuff that we shot for low budget but
you know when we got the opportunity to
work with heidi moneymaker and zoe bell
on this short film project called no
touching which is an action
horror piece about two girls who get
into this haunted house where the people
running it are
misogynistic and start grabbing and
touching them inappropriately
you don't do that to zoey bell or heidi
moneymaker because they're gonna kick
your ass
and that is that is what happens and no
touching they
they kick ass all throughout this
haunted house so it's very fun but
for that i mean we knew that it had to
be done right
you know so we didn't have access to 30
grand
so we had to resort to kickstarter which
was great
we got on board kickstarter and i was
like let's let's
try to fund it that way and that um was
a
great education that i think everybody
should try to do
even if they fail or not because you
learn
what it takes to get people's eyes you
know and
how hard it is to get people to care
and to give you money and you know
wanting to give them
rewards that are worth it it's a whole
exercise in marketing
that's super invaluable um
and just how to hustle but we did it for
15 days oh usually people go for 30.
wow but we thought about it a bit and
we're like
and we did a lot of research and we read
a lot of other case studies of people
who had done 30-day kickstarters
and it seems as if for a 30-day
kickstarter like there's a lot of like
activity in the beginning
but then for about like in the middle
section like 15 days
it just hits a wall and then when you're
at the last like 5 or 10 days then
there's a lot more activity
so it's like why not just cut out that
middle section
cut out the middle man and just do 15
days
and just hit it as hard as possible you
know so
all of it hopefully is that like you
know
furious period um and so that was a huge
gamble
trying to make 30 grand in 15 days wow
but
uh we eventually did it and
interestingly there was still that lull
right in the middle
you know i think that's just the nature
of it there's a lot of fury at the
beginning a lot of fury at the end no
matter if it's 15 or 30 days
but um but it was close it was real
really close i remember uh we had it set
to end
on noon of the final day of the 15th day
and the night before we were still
around
three or four grand off oh and it's like
how do we get three or four grand in
12 hours it was
you know i was like this is it this is
not gonna happen like
we're done you know we're thinking about
like is there anybody that we can call
there was nobody that we could call
everybody had already
chipped in right so i went to bed
and i was like i guess we'll see i guess
we'll see
and i remember being woken up at around
5 a.m
um by my sister who is texting me
furiously and i roll over i was like
what
what is this like what what is what's
the issue
and i remember the text she said she was
like you did it
i was like wait what do you mean and
she's like you you have to look at your
kickstarter you did it
and it turns out that in the middle of
the night
uh a gal i think from new zealand or or
england um who was a huge fan of zoe
bell
had shipped in the money and this is not
somebody that we had reached out to
um this is not somebody that we knew it
was just somebody who saw
this cool zoey bell project um
that somebody had randomly posted on a
xena messaging board
like a fan board for xena um
like nothing that we had reached out to
it's just somebody got a hold of it and
like
you know fate sort of took over but this
this gal was just like i'll put you over
the edge and she did it and i am
so thankful um because
we were able to make it and that feeling
is an amazing feeling um
and yeah and the product you know i i
think the final film turned out pretty
darn good
um so i'm glad that it exists you know
but it wouldn't have existed
if not for everybody who chipped in and
shared it
and helped out and uh yeah it was it was
great
very cool but even having a full-time
job you've been able to do
at least one feature a few shorts i
guess
and then raise a little over 30 000
right with your
your partner yep um so that's with a
full-time job
yes so here most people have that
opinion and i know i've been of that
opinion myself at times
where yeah that's that's like the
creativity killer but it sounds like for
some people though it's not you need
that discipline and look how productive
you've been i mean that's pretty
most people just do sort of one and done
and that's it you know i mean that's
that's pretty remarkable yeah yeah thank
you um
and that's it's just what what i need
you know and no matter what job it is
this is what i've learned no matter what
job
that i have because my passion for
filmmaking and my drive for it
and the need to do it is so strong i
will do it no matter what
and i think maybe now if i were to have
to get
you know go back to pain or something
like that it would obviously be harder
but i think i would still
be able to do it um i think that my
mindset has changed enough
over the years that it's like i'm
definitely to the point where
i need to make this happen you know i
need to make
writing and directing a full-time job
i need to make that the thing
because i can't be myself and i can't
really accomplish what i need to
accomplish for myself
without doing that you know i can't have
the filmmaking not be the focal point of
my life because it's what i'm meant to
do
and when you know that you're meant to
do something
anything else just can't compare
everything else is second best
you know so it's really to that point
now
sitting here almost 35 that
i i have to i don't know what i have to
do
but i have to keep doing it you know if
i can find a way to fund more shorts
i'm going to um because i have to keep
doing it you know that feeling that
love is too great and i need it
more and more in my life adam how do you
know this is what you're meant to do
filmmaking you know this is for you that
uh i think that's a tough question but i
also think uh i know how i can
answer that um it's
it's the feeling that i get when i do it
first and foremost um that it
really makes me feel most like myself
you know in in other stuff other jobs
and other situations
in life i definitely sometimes feel
like i'm not myself you know or i can't
be myself
i'm not my most authentic self i think
someone very smart
put it um but uh but
filmmaking that's where
that's where i really feel that um
and i love it you know it's
it's the sort of thing where in life if
you can
choose the pain you're given then that's
better than having
pain forced upon you um
and the fact that filmmaking
has all of these highs and lows and it
can be exhilarating
and it can be super painful
you know when you get rejected or when a
project doesn't come together
or a project that you've put out isn't
received
how you might want it to be received
like the fact that
those are the pain points that i can
choose
is is kind of great because it's all
part of it
you know like you can't have those sort
of dizzying highs of like
a film playing in a theater or a huge
crowd at fantasia
loving no touching like those are things
i'm gonna remember forever
you know but with that comes the
movie that comes out and no one cares
about or those
multiple multiple rejections from film
festivals that you think your film is
like a sure thing
and you get rejected and you never know
why you know it's just you get the sorry
thanks for submitting and that is
crushing you know the the
the not knowing like were other films
better was it just
the you know the film festival's taste
like you never know um but
telling stories and being able to
impact people and make them think and
make them feel
like if you can make an audience feel
like that
is an amazing almost
addicting feeling you know making an
audience laugh
or cringe or shed a tear
which i i'm hopeful my latest short can
do and
a few friends who have seen it it's it's
not quite released yet
but they've said that it has done that
and that is just
sort of an honor and an amazing feeling
um
to be able to connect with people and i
think that's really what it's all about
is that through my work and through the
stories that i want to tell
i'm connecting with people you know like
i may go to
a party or a place where i feel
uncomfortable and it's kind of hard to
talk to people right
but with filmmaking
like it's that same sort of connection
and it's easier to talk
to people in some ways you know through
storytelling
that's that's interesting too yeah i
know especially for people that
myself included sometimes if i'm in a
big group i freeze up and i'm just not
but if it's about a film or a story an
author
it's different because it's a shared
experience and so
there's just a comfortable realm you can
enter with that
with with a film that you spend so much
time with whether it's a short or a
feature
and then at some point i would imagine
there's almost like a letting go period
where you're like okay
it's out there it's been received for
better or worse and now
it's time for me to move on to something
new can you talk about that process of
where you where you come to that point
where you know it's time to now start
something new
totally yeah yeah and the latest example
of that of that is my feature film
broken ceiling
um so that was the one that we shot in
four days
um the one that i needed to get done
before you know i turned to 31
um that you know after sort of a year of
like
tinkering and sending it to festivals
and getting feedback from people
and like doing a little bit of
re-editing it finally found a
distributor
which was great and it was put up on you
know
amazon and itunes and tubey tv and
uh you know in february 2018 it came out
and there was that big sort of like oh
this is amazing like it's out there
and you hit the social media really hard
and you know we were able to get a
review from the la times that was pretty
complimentary
great and then we got a review from the
hollywood reporter which completely
destroyed us
um but i i made it a point to to send
emails to both the writers and thank
them
for that wow you know because uh
they spent an hour and a half of their
time
to review a super low budget
movie that was shot in four days you
know these are the film critics for the
la times and the hollywood reporter like
i had to thank them for that because
you know back in the day i would never
imagine having
my movie you know having a picture of it
and a review of it turn up in the
hard copy of the la times you know that
i could go down to the corner starbucks
and i did i literally did this as soon
as it came out my distributor was like
hey you're in
the la times printed edition i was like
oh my god i need these printed editions
where does one buy a newspaper nowadays
i don't know if these exist anymore
so i went to a couple places the liquor
store didn't have it i was like okay
cool
went to the starbucks god bless them
they had them
so i was like i need to buy all of your
copies and i did i bought all six of
them
um got some weird looks but it's like i
don't care i need that's proof
i got to have that moment that you hear
about that like you know the review
comes out in the trades and they go and
they buy it from the newsstand i got to
have that which was super cool
um so all of that was very exciting and
you know getting people to watch it when
it first came out it was great and
you know you push and you push and you
you know you get people to watch and
they start reviewing it on amazon and
like that's exciting
and you get to see what people think of
it as well and then you're doing the
outreach because
you know you want to get some rotten
tomatoes scores
um so you're reaching out and like
pinging
so many reviewers who you know don't
necessarily have the time
to review it um so you're getting
reviews here and there and that helps
and that's great and that's exciting um
and then you know it sort of starts to
taper off
like a few months in it starts to slow
down
um and then you start to think well what
can i do to keep it going you know
because you really wanted
to keep going because there's so many
people that can still watch it there's
there's so many different audience
members you know all around the
globe everywhere you know and so you're
like how do i reach them how do i reach
them
you know what's the best way to do that
um
and that can be successful or that can
be not successful
um myself i hired a social media firm to
sort of run
the instagram account because social
media is something that i'm not at all
talented in
and i don't have that much interest in i
know it's something that you have to do
but it is very very hard to cut through
the noise
because everybody is posting everything
at all hours
minutes seconds of the day that trying
to find your fans and keep them engaged
is fairly exhausting and
but can be ultimately rewarding and it
was and there were definitely some
successes
um but i found that i needed to start
letting it go because you know you're
not
if you can't really expand the you know
the people that are on your instagram
you know the followers for example it's
hard you're just kind of screaming the
same message at them over and over and
you're not giving them anything new
so you have to try to keep them engaged
with other things it may not be movie
focused you know like
if your movie you know has some social
commentary then you can pull up stuff
from the news
and talk about that like there's a lot
of ways to keep
social media interesting instead of like
always being like watch my movie because
people are going to turn that off
uh pretty quick um but yeah we did that
for six months solid
and had some decent results i i can't
say that there were amazing results
you know um but
you know it worked it worked for the
most part
but after that i realized that i had to
let it go a little bit you know like i
couldn't keep pushing it i would try to
get reviews where i could
but that big push was sort of over and i
needed to to let it go
and and work on something new you know
because i think for me
the worst thing that i could have done
like
is is to keep pushing that like if i
sitting here today
was still pushing broken ceiling super
super hard
um and not working on anything new
and not trying to do that then that
would be a big mistake
i think because you know it felt natural
at the point you know it was about maybe
about
yeah about a year in that it had been on
you know amazon and toby tv and all
those
i was like okay like i gotta push
something else and
and you gotta keep working on stuff of
course like and through that time i was
definitely working
on so many things in addition to
you know trying to push the film and
that's why i had to hire that social
media firm because
i knew that i needed to be creating new
stuff like
i knew that i needed to do a new short
you know
another feature i would have loved to do
but
the funding aspect is is quite difficult
to do but i knew that i could you know
self-fund another
small short do that work on something
else just keep that going because
the big thing was getting on set again
because
in 2015 was a heck of a year
because we shot no touching
um no we shot we shot broken ceiling
first in june
so i shot the feature broken ceiling
before we shot no touching which was
done in the fall
but imagine being able to shoot a
feature and a short in the same year
like that's kind of a dream um but then
i didn't step behind the camera
until february of this year of 2019
you know so that's three four years of
not
directing and i found that very hard you
know i was writing a lot
but i wasn't behind the camera you know
because it's hard to squeeze in time to
do that when you're trying to put out a
feature
and get people interested in that and
then writing other projects
you know so yeah
it was good to get behind the camera
again
how do you know if your film found the
intended audience or maybe there is no
intended audience
maybe it's just whoever likes the story
i mean broken ceiling has a female
protagonist
it's about a contentious workplace
it's male driven different things that
this person's fighting against
did you have a specific audience or
anybody you wanted just anybody who was
interested in a good story to find it
um we did have a specific audience
i don't think that people who are really
into sci-fi
or horror would necessarily like it
i needed to find the people that were
into dramas
people who you know worked
office jobs day jobs women women of
color specifically because it's about a
woman of color and a
primarily white male dominated workspace
those were really you know the people
the true core audience for that um
and when we started seeing the sort of
like engagement demographics
on instagram that's what we found it was
interesting though because it was
it was a sort of male female split like
female but very split between males and
females so it was great that
a female empowerment story really had
you know legs with
male eyes um who were interested in that
and you wrote it as well yeah i did yeah
yeah what what prompted you
to write it for especially from a female
perspective sure sure
um the reason that i i
needed to tell the broken ceiling story
is because i started
writing it um just based on
sort of my general frustrations
with with how the world was working and
of course
the fact that i had not made a feature
yet you know so i was very
just in general frustrated and the story
is born of that frustration and you can
see that sort of frustration and all the
characters you know all the characters
are sort of
doing something that maybe they wouldn't
want to do you know or forced into these
roles that maybe are not the best for
them
so i started writing this a little bit
from my own perspective
and then you know there was
a a lot of social stuff that was going
on at the time
um uh the ferguson you know
shooting that happened everything came
out of that
and uh it really sort of hit me you know
it made me sort of open my eyes and go
you know what like
i i am you know a white male and
perhaps there are things that
i didn't realize you know about
ways that i've been helped out
unknowingly just being a white male you
know what benefits
have i had that maybe i wasn't aware of
and i realized that
i didn't want to tell that story
because i wanted to give a voice to
you know a character who maybe didn't
have a voice
so that's why i decided i completely
revised what i was going for
and i decided that i would do something
that you know
at the time i was sort of afraid to do
you know because you know with how
society was and still is
it was sort of like how dare i as a
white male
write you know from a perspective of a
black female and a black female story
um and that was that was something that
people were like
uh i feel uncomfortable with that like
because you don't know
that experience and truly i did not know
that experience at all
you know who was i to to write you know
a story about a black female
who had a hard time moving up you know
breaking the glass ceiling in a
corporate environment
um but what i did was
research i was like i need to tell the
story
and i need to know you know so i did a
lot of online research
i read a lot of stories about you know
black women in the workplace women
growing up
um talked to people you know really did
as
much research as i could do and i wrote
it
you know sort of on a wing and a prayer
um
and i thought that it turned out pretty
well and then when we were getting into
casting
um we i was meeting with uh
the woman who would eventually become
angela karen kendrick
and i remember the first meeting that we
had she had read the script
and i was kind of terrified to meet her
because i'm like
you know what are you gonna think of
this story um
and i will forever remember what she
said but she goes
it's like you told my story my personal
story
and that was the highest compliment that
i could get because all the research all
the hours put in like
it paid off it was authentic which is
super important and it spoke to her
which was the most important thing um
and yeah she she signed on and
she was fantastic and amazing to work
with
and i learned even more you know through
working with her
um and uh you know it it
it was a wonderful working relationship
and she's gone on to do
amazing things and will very very soon
be an enormous
enormous star because she's so talented
so the fact that she
wanted to work on this tiny project and
and felt connected to it
was great and i'm just super grateful
that i was able to get her
and the rest of the cast because yeah
i was very blessed with the performances
and the actors and that's something that
you know people definitely call out when
they review it
they love karen they love the other
actors
you know it's it's it's exciting to see
them
you know get that recognition which they
they definitely deserve
do people actually tell you don't tell
this story
like you don't have the right because
you don't authentically know it
or don't go there man like just just let
it be
like what did they say uh it was all
about the
how they felt uncomfortable that a white
man was telling a black woman's story
you know and and i totally get that i
understand it
because i did not i did not know
i didn't grow up with that you know but
the thing that i truly believe about
writers
um and directors is that they are able
to
inhabit different points of view and
different characters like
you have to to be able to write
characters who are different from you
you have to empathize
with them you have to do the research
you have to learn about that like
and i think that writers are are fully
equipped to be able to you know write
from somebody else's
perspective you know and i think we
should
you know i think that anybody should be
able to write anything
provided that they do the research and
they do it
authentically that is 100 the most
important thing like you have to immerse
yourself you have to do the research
and you have to make sure that it is
true otherwise
otherwise you shouldn't do it and maybe
that's what they were afraid of that i
was just going to assume or imagine what
it would have been like
to be a black woman and you know a white
male
dominated industry um but i didn't i
did the work because i had to make it
true
and and i hope that that comes out
and then were there people that said
thank you for doing this i know this is
not
where you live so to speak in head space
but yeah thank you for trying to
to tell someone else's story that needs
to be told yeah i mean in the reviews
like uh honestly the the best reviews
that i
got were women of color you know and
people
of color reviewing it and going
this is truthful this strikes a chord
the fact that it connected with them
is the highest compliment the highest
praise that i can get and when you said
you got some reviews that weren't
favorable
was it of that nature or was it
other things it was actually other
things oh i see it
which is which is kind of nice yeah all
of the criticisms were directed at me
you know in terms of like you know maybe
the story could have used this
like a lot of it um was a little bit
story based
about like well you know because it is
so hard
to try to tell you know a story in one
location
it is so hard and i don't know if i hit
it out of the park
i think i did a decent job um but
trying to you know ring 90 minutes
out of one location is so hard um so i
did my best but i've been knocked a
little bit
for that um but but praised for the
directing
which i appreciate and the thing that i
appreciate about
those reviews is that it makes me go
oh great there's something that i can
work on there's something that i may be
lacking
that um i need to be better at
and that i found is like just classic
dramatic
narrative structure like the art of
dramatic writing
that's what i've been doing you know for
the past six months
or to a year is just really nailing that
aspect you know because i can do visuals
i can work with actors i can do this i
can do that
but like really getting those
fundamental tenets of storytelling is is
very
important at least for me and without
those reviews that were negative you
know how do you learn
you know because i wouldn't have if
everybody would have gone oh this is
great
keep it up don't change you don't learn
anything from that
and i want to keep getting better so the
fact that there were criticisms
leveled at me it's like thank you now i
can make the next one
even better because i don't want to be
treading water like i need
the next one to be better and the latest
short i did
i can say with certainty that it is
better
than the feature that i did you know and
the feature i still think is very good
but the fact that i can do a new project
and
for myself know that there's a benchmark
of getting better
that's you know that's paramount
importance to me
how do you know a protagonist is a
character you want to write about
like how do you know you're really
connected to that protagonist
that's a very very good question um
i think for me it comes from
a little bit of the story and about
what i want to say at that time
um i don't tend to tend to go with
you know tropes of characters i really
go with like what's the situation and
what character
can be tested the most in that situation
you know um the most recent
thing that my writing partner will and i
have done is a horror feature
with a lot of like very social you know
very topical social
commentary and that just came out of
you know a specific very interesting
idea of horror
but also the fact that right now
um there's a lot of of uh
you know disparity in terms of people's
pay
um just in the world you know the rich
are getting richer and the poor getting
poorer and that middle class is
disappearing and everything
and that's been very top of mind for me
um
so i wanted a protagonist for this
horror script
that really like embodied that and
somebody like this
blue-collar worker in chicago that we
can all identify with
and get behind because i i think at
least i do but i
think that we all feel like we are that
person
right now you know like the corporations
you know they're just stepping down on
us and politics is stepping down on us
and
you know there's there's a lot of unrest
and and upheaval i think
and uh yeah it's just it's one of those
things that the situation sort of
can dictate that and and it's something
that i'm finding
that having very socially conscious
statements
is something that i really want to put
out there
um because i think that i mean films are
are a great medium um
that you know you can reach a lot of
people with and
if i can put messages in there
you know that will make people think of
something a different way
you know like thinking about the
disparity between black people and white
people and
uh you know in a corporate environment
um
or you know with no touching it was
about you know the reach of misogyny
you know uh i really want topical
you know things that people can just
really sink their teeth into and make
them think
that's that's my big goal with with my
current projects at least
what were the movies growing up that
were like that that made you
think about sort of social commentary
like i like norma ray comes to mind i
know that's
before my time even but you know it's
not just a feminist story but it's also
a story about a small town
yeah people being scared to lose their
jobs is the only place for them to work
yeah and being like
just they you know all of them are sick
and different things are happening
but what what different uh films growing
up sure
um i think for me what's interesting
is that it wasn't really like dramas or
things like that
i found those messages in like sci-fi
and and popcorn films at the time so the
matrix
was like the first one that really
opened my mind
to you know the thought of uh
you know what if none of this is real
you know like just
the mind expanding aspect of like really
looking at the systems that we have and
and
trying to figure out like how much of
this is real how much of it is not
um and that continues on with v for
vendetta
which i think is you know an amazing
piece that again
really gets you thinking um even though
it's you know like
comic book and action and that's stuff
that i just love and i'm drawn to
but the ones that feed in that social
commentary
are great and children of men is another
example
of just you know a sort of cautionary
tale
about the future um so those are the
ones that i would say
really sort of did a great job of you
know
it's popcorn movies but sneaking in
um some very important social commentary
i've been on a raymond chandler kick and
so i've been
researching just different panels and
this usc panel
talked about his writings and he just
said that so much of noir was a
commentary
on on really the working class versus
the wealthy especially in
la in the 30s and all this corruption
and just
sort of just you know
paid off politicians versus sort of the
working man yeah and so it's just
interesting because you wouldn't
totally you see it as more of just a
mystery but that
woven in is this commentary yeah and
that's that's the real
great trojan horse aspect of film it's
like people are there to be entertained
but if you can you know sort of
trick them a little bit and uh and give
them a little dose of social commentary
that they'll go out going like
what was that actually about or i'm
thinking about that now or opens their
eyes like
that's great that's a wonderful trick
how long did it take you to write broken
ceiling the script
it took me about a month to write the
first draft
and then i would say another month and a
half of
rewrites to really get it to a filmable
spot
and where would you write it uh at home
in my office on my computer
so knowing you had the day job and so
now you knew what time
you could work on did you have specific
times you would yeah it was
pretty much when i get in the zone of
writing um
i need to do it like every day so
i i found myself coming home having
dinner
talking with my wife then going to write
and then going to bed
waking up going to work doing that same
thing again
until the thing was completed and there
were at points where
i would do it in the morning as well as
the night i would wake up in the morning
because my head was just like
burning like i've got to get this stuff
out there so i'd wake up
write go to work come home eat write
go to bed etc
do you finish most everything that you
start uh yeah
i do because to not
finish something really bothers me
um it's tough seeing like you know
half written scripts like i don't
actually have any like non-written
scripts like they're all written
not to say that they're all great you
know or that they don't need rewrites
because a lot of them do
but um but i need to at least
have that full like 90 100 pages or
whatever
done and like projects like i i
definitely won't start
something that i can't finish because i
need
not only like to check it off my mental
list but
to sort of follow through and to follow
through not for anybody you know like
i'm not doing this for anybody but for
myself
that's the most important thing like
when i set
a goal or a date um
i'm gonna do it you know and what's
interesting
is that i find that people are kind of
shocked by that um
my crew on my latest short that i shot
in february called losing sight
um had a very quick time frame on it
it's like we're gonna shoot it in one
day here's what i need to have the edit
done here's when this is
done like i have a couple of months i
have to get it done
you know then they're like well what for
and i'm like
i mean festivals probably but like
you know i just need to get it done and
that was the time
that i had allotted myself and you know
i remember a few of them being just sort
of like shocked when it came in they're
like oh it's done
because i guess they're used to people
maybe taking their time
uh with projects or just abandoning them
or not finishing them and i just
that's unthinkable to me because like
people are putting their time and energy
into something and i want to be able to
go ahead and have it out there you know
for them
and for me especially like it's
got to get done you know no matter what
when you wrote broken ceiling did you
know it would be one location
yeah i wrote it with one location in
mind
because i knew that i would only have
like four days to shoot it
because that's all i could budget for
you know again very small budget
um so i liked the fact that you know
having it in one location meant that we
could really
just crank through a feature and get it
all done
um but also
to you know just
yeah i don't know where i was going with
that one oh no that's okay and it was 4
that you spent on production no more
than oh
the budget was more than four thousand
four was the days
that we spent shooting okay yeah yeah so
it was done over two weekends
so again working during the week
shooting over the weekend working during
the week shooting it over the weekend
those were
those were some harried like you know
couple weekends in a row
um but yeah it was great and and for the
one location
i knew that to be able to shoot 90 pages
in four days i had to be very strategic
with it
so the one the biggest and most
important thing that i decided to do
was to shoot with natural lighting
because it was set in an office space
and i
wanted that very oppressive fluorescent
look um and originally i had designed it
that it was just going to be like
almost like wes anderson in terms of
like long
takes and a lot of like monologues and
and
it's very much and people have
attributed it to feeling more
um like a stage play than anything
which is is kind of how it was written
but but yeah like doing all natural
lighting
and rehearsing the actors for two
straight weeks ahead of time
because letting everybody know we have
four days we're not going to get a lot
of takes
you know so we'll get a couple of them
but like let's get everything
out through rehearsal and so we did that
and everybody was on board for that
in-game
and that's really how we were able to
accomplish it like everybody came in
on the first day knowing what they had
to do we didn't have to
on the day sort of experiment and try
and fail like we had done all that like
we knew where we needed to be
we knew where we were going and there
was a lot of dialogue a hell of a lot of
dialogue
and a couple like long monologues you
know it was very much
i had to treat it more like a theater
exercise
in terms of you know the prep than
anything
and i think you had said something that
i read
it might have been for for film courage
or or in your video diary
that the power dynamics changed and so
the way you shot it
changed did you also write that into the
script or was that something
that during those four days you came up
with um
that happened uh post-writing of the
script but through the storyboarding
phase
that is something that i really had to
do
because when you're limited on time you
have to know exactly
what you're going to shoot so i
storyboarded the heck out of that
and then as always happens
you know when you get on set suddenly
you have to throw that out
right um and the director of photography
jessa was
jessica was great because uh i had
you know that that thought in mind of
like all right i'll do this
long takes wes anderson thing and she's
like you know what
i think we can get more coverage i think
we can do more with this
and i was like great let's do that so
it was sort of an on the fly like let's
get these shots let's
let's do this let's do that so a lot of
it sort of strayed a little bit from the
storyboards
and was improvisational in the moment
and the fact that we can move so fast
because we didn't have to deal with like
moving lights and everything
allowed everybody to sort of like get
going so it was very
creatively energizing um and
improvisational
it was a great time so when you finished
your first draft
um who did you give it to to see like
not only is
is the story good but am i writing from
the appropriate voice for this
protagonist sure um
oh i gave it to to a few people um
i gave it to of course like my writing
partner will for his notes
um my wife read it she had a couple of
friends
you know who she knows who she had them
read and it was really through
you know her friends um that let me go
like okay
like it is authentic like they are
telling me
oh this reads i feel that i understand
that
um so it was really sort of casting it a
little bit wider
than i would like i'm not going to have
my wife's friends read every script that
doesn't
you know make sense but uh but for that
it was important
to make sure that like that litmus test
that initial test was
was like okay like i'm on the right
track it is getting
there it is truthful like all right good
i'm feeling you know on solid ground
and is it you said heavy on dialogue
yeah so
you're writing these different dialogue
scenes are you when you're driving to
work are you like thinking of this
dialogue like i said
are you on the 10 this time you're
definitely looking at the car in front
of you
but but you're like no she would say
this and i think he would you know like
is that where you're coming up with a
lot of this rich dialogue you know some
of it
but i i found that a lot of it was
coming out as i was writing
um i did a lot of outlining beforehand
and i did a lot of character work
beforehand so
the characters just started to exist
in my brain and you know in reality um
and so when i was writing things like
things would come
out of angela's mouth or ken's mouth
that i'm like oh my god like wow
that's good but i can't take credit for
that you know like that's
the characters and maybe this sounds
crazy or not but um
but it's like those characters really
came to life and we're saying these
things and i was
you know sort of sometimes in awe at
what they were saying and i look back
now and i'm like yeah i i couldn't have
written that like how did i
myself write that it was the characters
you know they came to life and they sort
of made that
you know happen
can you talk about the character work
absolutely yes
um so for the character work for broken
ceiling
um i did that all freehand uh
because i found that there's a more
uh you know using less technology more
organic
you know if i can sit there with a
notepad and a pen
um especially for the early stuff i find
that
um to just work for me in general so
i would just sit there and i knew the
characters that i needed
um and i was like trying to figure out
what
what are their dynamics you know it's
four people in an office
they're stuck on this high pressure call
on a sunday you know so they're
overworked
what types of characters you know
would be best to bounce off each other
you know like how do we get more
drama in it so i i
sort of pulled from my own life and
pulled from people that i knew
and then i you know did a lot of online
research
you know going on on blogs about
business and blogs about you know
just people in general and just reading
about people and learning their stories
and doing a hell of a lot of research
with you know how people operate in the
workplace and and it was more than just
like
you know let me look at these character
stuff it was just
general writings you know from like you
know the harvard business reviewer stuff
like that just about workplaces in
general
you know even though i knew about a
corporate environment you know being in
it for so many years
all of that you know just ancillary
research things that you wouldn't think
matter in terms of building a character
um i
used and that definitely informed
the characters as i was building them
but it was it was a lot of free hand
you know a lot of just writing trying to
figure out who these characters were
you know like if you have angela you
know who's the beleaguered assistant
who's been there 10 years and who's
never been
promoted like who's the guy that she's
gonna hate
you know and it's somebody who has been
there only a short amount of time and
who's had these opportunities
and who's been pushed above her you know
and how would she
react and how would they react and what
does he think of her and what does she
think of him
and then you know off of that character
tyler who's a character that's
threatening to him
you know it's somebody even newer um
and how is that dynamic you know does
this character look at this older
character sort of as a model
and is he sort of modeling also
tyler's bad behaviors and you know the
wrong things that he does and then of
course you know the
the big the big boss ken um who
reagan wilson really knocked it out of
the park with that character but
you know what is for that character is
like what is the worst possible boss
you know i haven't had a lot of terrible
bosses
i've been very lucky and that my bosses
have been very good and helpful and
supportive
and wonderful so i was like what is you
know a terrible boss and the movie
whiplash
was one of those you know one of those
things where it's like that guy
you know jk simmons's character in
whiplash he's awesome yeah he's
such a bastard and i was like i kind of
wanted that sort of like
big villain like my goal with ken was to
make him
sort of an iconic just bastard of cinema
and and i think that me and me and
reagan were able to sort of craft that
character and make
him sort of stand out that's what i was
going to ask you next actually you're
reading my mind what what other movies
did you watch like swimming with sharks
or
i know there's one with parker posey
where she actually picked she's
fantastic
she's actually the female boss who's
just i think i don't know if she's like
in love with the male co-worker but she
just becomes like this complete psycho
it's great to watch she's fantastic i
mean like whiplash swimming with sharks
of course
devil wears prada okay anything with
like a terrible
boss i was like i gotta i gotta see how
they did it like
let me gain something from that right
interesting
so you had written many short
screenplays before
i'm not sure how many features you'd
written but
was your process the same for all of
them
my process changed um a bit as i was
going there was definitely a phase
um in my mid-20s where i brought out the
cork board
and started doing like the cue cards you
know on the board like all right here's
act one here are the scenes and
here's act 2 etc um and i sort of fell
away from that because what i
found and this is the process that i
found on broken ceiling that really
worked for me
was just going into a word doc
and making a very descriptive outline i
think the outline for the film was about
20 pages
oh wow um and i would i would write like
1 through ten
what's happening there 11 through 20
and just break it sort of down you know
because i needed
to make sure that the audience was kept
on their toes
throughout the entire thing so i needed
to know okay like what's going on in
this
10 minute sequence what's going on in
the next 20 minutes how do i make that
different from that how do i make these
twists like where does this come into
the thing
like making it so that it's the most
dramatic
and enjoyable thing that it can be
um but i found and that's what i've used
ever since is like
just making r almost pre-writing
the movie which is interesting i'll just
you know free type and and
write everything sometimes there's
dialogue included sometimes there's not
sometimes it's just descriptions
but if dialogue comes out write that
down it's a good starting point
but i just go through and you know they
they range from 10 to 20 to sometimes 30
pages
based on the project or how long it is
but i really like
writing out the movie in full so i can
have that word doc open as i'm writing
the script and sort of like
compare and go okay this is working this
is working or changing things if
if i find that something doesn't work
all of a sudden
do you write most of your projects with
will yeah most of them will and i have
written
how did you meet well uh we met at the
uh
at the internship um at the production
company that i worked for
um and it was through our you know
working together at the company that
uh we forged this creative bond and you
know
it was early on and we've just sort of
continued since
so when you let's suppose you meet up i
don't know for coffee or i don't know
how you discuss ideas but how do you
know that an idea is viable
that it's actually going to last through
the whole process um
[Music]
i think that if it excites me
or excites us that's a good starting
point
um is it an idea that i haven't heard of
before
is it something that perhaps is topical
or
perhaps as something that had been done
before but has fallen out of fashion
and could use a resurgence you know like
what's
it's thinking about like you know
keeping your finger on the pulse
what's going to be current now but also
because
film takes so long to get done what's
going to be
still relevant like three years from now
and sometimes you can't gauge that and
you can't know that
so in terms of viability for me
it's really boils down to like
what i need to say you know
like what it what is current in me and
what's interesting in that
is that when i and we have followed that
we come up with things like no touching
that you know back in 2016 when that
came out
um this was before the me too movement
right but it was sort of like in that
realm of just seeing where the wind was
blowing broken ceilings sort of
same thing like made that before like
everybody else had in a way
caught on and had become a bigger thing
so not to say that we're you know like
predicting
the future but it's just seeing what's
going on and sort of catching those
early
you know that early wind of something
and then
if it resonates with us going on
and and pushing it through if
it can excite us and hold our attention
because that's the thing
sometimes you'll get an idea and uh
it's good for the moment and then you
realize that you can't commit
everything that you need to commit to it
and then it can sort of like fall away
and put in the slush pile
you know for a rainy day where do you
find your news
like are you going you're listening to
npr where are you finding like stuff
that's topical
just to sort of like open your mind and
say like oh wow this is happening this
seems to be a trend okay
sure yeah i i just general like a little
bit of npr
some cnn um just
online blogs and news sites and stuff
like that podcasts are great
you know for keeping up with that stuff
the daily show with trevor noah is
is wonderful too um bill maher
in terms of like politics you know like
sort of mixing the
the news with like comedy and stuff i i
find that's
that's helpful because it gives you like
a different perspective on it
um and they're the ones you know
comedians in general that kind of like
tell the truth
a bit more um which i think is always
good
and it's entertaining entertaining
anyway right
what do you think about someone like a
lenny bruce who was penalized for
sort of telling the truth and now we're
in a new culture where that's embraced
but at that time
you know his shows were being you know i
mean
how do you feel about that at one time
it was taboo to sort of
speak the truth in that sense yeah not
that it's totally embraced now but right
um but more so it's okay to sort of have
a snarky take on the truth
yeah whereas back in the day it was
far too offensive sure um i think it's
good
that those sort of barriers have broken
down a bit
um i think that people definitely
appreciate i think they need the truth
um because there's a lot of
misinformation and people are being fed
things
you know inside their own bubble that
they believe to be true and i think
that's
you know something that's sort of
dividing us right now
so it's always good to sort of see what
other people are talking about or where
they're getting their news
for example but yeah
i think that we're more to a place where
we can be more honest but there's still
certain things
that you know as you mentioned like it's
not
fully embraced right now i think maybe
we might be backtracking a little bit
into you know you can't say certain
things
otherwise the twitter mob is going to
get you and then
you're screwed which you know as as an
artist
is an interesting thing to deal with
um not that i've had to deal with it but
for the people that have i can imagine
how trying that is
but yeah it's sort of a tough line to
walk nowadays
yeah and it's tough too because you
click on one story and now that reality
is continually fed back
because that algorithm thinks oh this is
what you want to see okay
this is what's in karen's feed this is
what's in adam's feed so we're going to
feed him more of that we're going to
feed her more of that
so you're only fed back more of your own
beliefs yeah
and so it's just interesting because it
could be a distorted reality on my part
and i could be
working on things that the rest of the
world doesn't see it that way but
yeah you're right about the the mob
coming out to you
what do you think are your strengths and
what do you think you
could work more on in terms of
filmmaking storytelling
sure i think my strengths
are in thinking in visual terms
definitely being able to you know put
together
a series of images into something that's
cohesive and affecting
i think is one of my strongest suits um
working with
actors i've definitely been getting
better at it's something that i wanted
to work on
you know just in general how to speak to
actors how to talk to them how to give
them what they need
having the confidence you know to work
with that
um in terms of writing
i i think my character work is really
solid and my dialogue i think is very
good as well
uh it's story structure that is probably
something that i'm a little weaker at um
because in terms of like that classic
sort of aristotle or plato
sense um i could i could stand to
you know do a little bit more uh
figuring out about like you know what
makes
this structure work because classic
structure you know works for a reason
and you know like as shakespeare sort of
shows it's the basis of
you know all good storytelling so sort
of you know going away from the the
young man conventions of like
breaking conventions without really
understanding the conventions so that's
something that i've
definitely been working on and as you
know something that
i could you know i'm a bit weak at
why do you think so just someone told
you that or you just
look at your work and and you feel that
way or
um i think honestly some of the reviews
of broken ceiling sort of brought that
to light
uh where they're like hey you know the
directing's great the acting's great
like the dialogue but some of the story
points
were fumbled to the film's detriment
that is a quote
from i don't know if that's the
hollywood reporter one oh okay
um but it's like okay yeah like story
points like
figuring out how to keep something
propulsive
and dramatic you know like how do you
really
do that well and i think that's
something that like if a writer can do
that then they are
golden and they'll get a ton of work um
but yeah it's something that i've had to
realize like okay
like i'm focusing too much on like you
know the characters and
and the dialogue and how do i get a
really good sort of
story structure in there have you read
books on story structure are you
into reading books on stories yeah yeah
yeah i i have a few of them that are on
my list
i am currently reading the art of
dramatic writing
um which ron howard recommends as
as something that he goes back to um
i got a subscription to master class
oh great which i highly recommend i've
learned a ton
from scorsese and howard um
and uh yeah there's a lot of stuff there
um which is pretty great and
uh it's it's just the thing that i've
found
is that i don't want to get comfortable
with my knowledge
because i don't know everything and i
need to keep
learning so reading books that i haven't
read and doing these master class
courses like keep learning
is something that i really need to do
because i only want to get better
you know and i know that i'm not
comfortable going like okay this is what
i do
and this is that because that would make
me stagnant and i can't
can't live with that oh what an
interesting take i like that
most people wouldn't two things i i find
very interesting that you're you're
grateful
however painful it was to get a bad
review and you thanked a person for that
and then not wanting to get stuck in
your knowledge yeah
that's really interesting i don't know
if a lot of people think like that
well they should i mean it's something
that i knew i was you know
like i'm almost 35 and i could sit back
and go well i've made a feature and i've
made
a bunch of shorts and like i know what
i'm doing i'm good but it's like you
know what
like get people to
to read your stuff and watch your stuff
and give you real
constructive feedback you know like the
worst is when
when people are just like oh yeah that
was great it's like
thank you for that that feels good but
tell me what
tell me what i did wrong what didn't
work for you what could have been
better because i need to know that in
order to get better because i want to
make films at the highest level
and unless i am learning and
consistently trying to improve myself
i'm not going to be able to do that so
there is no resting on on my laurels
like i will read
anything and everything like right now
even though i'm not in production
on anything it's still the same thing
and i've been doing this
for 10 plus years where i will come home
and you know i will write something or i
will read something or i will write and
read something
like i did last night you know i cranked
out a couple of chapters of that
did you know one of the lessons on
masterclass and
did a revision to the new short that i'm
doing you know and that's
all at night and i'm lucky that i have
the time
that i can do that you know now so i
take i
try to take full advantage of that so
you read a little
bit from the art of dramatic writing yep
you watched
one part of the master class and then
you worked on a a short screenplay
yep wow it's pretty disciplined
i mean i have to be if i want to get the
most workout
that i possibly can like i have to keep
doing that you know
and of course like i you know i'm not
working all the time
like you need breaks you know you need
to watch movies you need to go out
experience the world you know you can't
just be doing that because then
you're not getting the fuel from the
world that can help you
you know write and direct and
think of new stories like that's super
important like right now i'm not
currently in the
the you know trying to look for stories
mode right now i'm in
trying to figure out okay like what's
truthful about you know
the world of independent wrestling right
like that's where i'm at so i'm in
full-on sort of research and writing
mode and going to shows
and talking with wrestlers and and
trying to figure that out you know so
that this
this short film can really you know be
something
sort of special and like right now like
it's it's tough
because i i wrote the first draft
and uh i got a bunch of people excited
about it
and that's super exciting because you
know they're willing to sort of move
heaven and earth and accommodate me and
they want to see this made
and i wrote it and you know i sent it
over to will and he's like
i have i have a lot of thoughts you know
and he's a very good
harsh critic and he's very honest you
know and it's
totally what i need you know it's what i
thrive on and i know he thrives
on it too but it's sort of like right
now i'm like okay
like how do i make this work does
it work and that's the scariest part
like i have a draft of something i have
people excited about it but
is it actually going to work did i did i
make this premise
and there's a core tenant of it that's
broken that i didn't realize
until now that it's in front of me you
know and if it is broken
how do i fix that how do i make it
something that
works or is it completely broken
and i shouldn't do it at all and i can't
do it at all
i hope that that's not the case i don't
think it will be
it's just how do i get more creative how
do i figure out
and target what the issues are and
figure out how do i make that
dramatically satisfying while
sticking to the message the reason why
i'm making that and that's
the biggest point is is you have to know
why you're making it and you have to
stick to that
you know i was thinking of some other
ideas about like okay i could take it
this way i could go that way
but i found that they were changing the
tone and it wasn't
exactly what i loved about it and it
didn't stick to
the central reason why i'm so excited to
tell this story so
you got to find out like where
in the realm of other possibilities
can you make this thing better while
retaining the reason why and the passion
why you're making it
did you wrestle in high school i did
yeah oh okay
i wrestled uh in middle school in high
school
um i was super small i was the smallest
guy on the team
i got my butt kicked a lot i was pinned
a lot i lost a lot
i only won two matches in my entire time
but i think doing that really
sort of set me up for
this job and this career because
there's so many losses that you have to
figure out how to take a loss
and how to learn from it and i you know
connecting those two things about like
losing and wrestling and trying to
figure out how to get better
and getting a bad review and a film
and going okay well how do i get better
the next time like those are all
connected
you know so very early on i think that's
where i got this sense of like
tell me you know what's wrong
let me fail i'm okay with failing i'm
okay with rejection you know
it hurts but it doesn't break me and it
doesn't stop me you know it only makes
me want to get better
and do better and those are public
failures too so you're comparing the two
wrestling and filmmaking yeah and
learning how and you got to get back up
and i don't know if you shake hands or
whatever but then
that sounds like that's what you've
already put into practice
yeah it definitely is so you've decided
you want to tell this wrestling story
and it's a short film absolutely yeah
yeah
something that i think could be turned
into a feature at some point but like a
short is definitely
right for this idea right now and it's
set in the in the world of independent
wrestling
um which is something that i love i love
wrestling i love wwe i love independent
wrestling
um so you know being able to meet the
wrestlers and see what they go through
on an independent level the grind that
they have to do
you know the fact that they have to
spend
20 minutes breaking their body
entertaining fans
and then they're done and right after
they go out to the lobby of the vfw or
the small hall that they're wrestling at
and have to sell merch you know they're
dripping sweat
they're injured they're aching and they
have to you know put on a happy face and
like
you know sell some t-shirts and glossies
and like take pictures
and it's just it's amazing because like
the passion that they have for that
i totally identify with and i attribute
it to the passion that i have
for filmmaking did you see the
documentary for um
the story that prompted fighting with my
family paige
i did not see the documentary i still
need to i saw fighting with my family
he's cool it is really great steven
merchant
did a such such a good job with that
he's the screenwriter yes screenwriter
an actor and director and he's an actor
i think he shows up
yes hilarious as one of the dads i think
yeah and i actually
not that not that i'm in fighting with
my family however
when they shoot the very end uh you know
the sort of like wrestling match between
paige and aj lee
um they shot it after an episode of
monday night raw which i was at
oh cool so i was able to go and like see
them actually shoot you know
this scene between them and how they
only had an hour
and how they had to you know get the
crowd going because the live crowd was
there and how they had to shoot specific
things and how quickly they worked
it was fascinating yeah i think it's on
youtube
the documentary it's it's really
fascinating yeah
you mentioned something earlier about
creating story worlds where did that
come from where did that occur to you
most people probably don't think again
in those terms
where where is this coming from the
story world idea sure
um well uh will and i uh
we had this idea for the sci-fi series
so we were pretty interested in how do
we
make a world a sci-fi world that doesn't
exist yet
you know like because there have been
great iconic sci-fi worlds created
and we wanted to do something sort of on
that level um
but we had to figure out like how to
build a world which is a super
hard and fascinating thing to do you
know so it's like if
if there's this technology that we
create like how does that affect the
world
you know uh let's let's try to build
that up you know so we
we started thinking about you know the
macro
stuff like how does
politics work how does religion work how
are people
how does this technology affect them um
and you just sort of go
out in these branches and try to
nail down this world because you have to
be super
specific you know because you need to
know how everything
operates you know how people would react
in this world
do they speak differently um did this
piece
of technology alter it in that way
um you know and in doing all of that
work and we spent
i would say a solid six months just
building the world
before we even wrote the story
you know we had a general idea of what
we wanted the story
to be you know going back to like what
we're trying to say
um but we had to really flesh out this
world
and figure out what would work and what
didn't work
and how it was different from other
things
and and how it had touch points of
similarities so it's not
so alien that people you know are sort
of thrown by it
can't get into it um but yeah a full
at least six months trying to create
this thing in order to just start
thinking about the story and the
characters that would really populate it
do you ever listen to some of the
science fiction authors or or
screenwriters
on how they've like a philip k dick or
whatever on how they would
create worlds or or just the headspace
they were in i realized some of it was
maybe chemically induced with some but
you know even like ursula k le guin just
she was a mother of four and then she's
coming up with these amazing
worlds i don't know how she's doing it
um and then
seems incredibly sane in these
interviews you know and
do you ever listen to just these people
in their process
you know i haven't really um it was sort
of the thing where
we just made what we thought would be a
good process ourselves like
let's just sort of blue sky this and it
was just a series of long conversations
and you know just figuring out
what we thought would work and and what
sort of bumped against what could work
maybe it's best you didn't because then
you might try to emulate sure
that style and then and then it's too
cliche right and then it's like oh i see
what they were going for
they were trying to do you know scanner
darkly or something you know
have you carried that world building
over into other projects or it's just
for this one that you're working on
specifically now with will
i think um maybe not the world
building itself but how we
created um sort of one a working
relationship
and and how we thought of ideas
and stories i think that's what we
really took for it you know for example
um i didn't need to create this whole
like big world
document for broken ceiling because it's
you know set in now
in an industry that i know that i'm you
know aware of
um so for something like that i didn't
need to do
um you know if something's set in in
present day or in the world you don't
necessarily
have to do that however for this period
piece
uh pilot about minors that we wrote
we did have to create a world there too
because
you know it's set in the 1920s which we
obviously didn't live through
and then it was like well do we want to
make a heightened version of that
do we want to you know stick straight to
the historical accuracy
um so that was something that was sort
of a follow-up project to that
where you know even though it's it's a
period piece
we still had to sort of create that
world like how these characters would
live
so it really depends on on the story and
where it is in time and i
assume that if i was going to make
something
uh you know in present day there was
something that i didn't even know about
you know set in another country or
whatever i would have to do that same
sort of world building
as well you know based on research of
course
do you ever put a time limit on your
research because i would imagine it
would become extremely fun
sure yeah i mean um i'm not
as much as i've had to do research it's
not my favorite part
um i really want to get to the writing
and the story breaking and the character
stuff um
but uh but yeah there there is
a thing and this goes not only for world
building research but character research
there is such a thing as too much
research
you know like for example you don't need
to necessarily
know what a character was doing
when they were eight years old right you
may not need
to create that much of a character
background or history
if this character is in their 30s
you know and it's said over the course
of a week like
how much is that really going to inform
you or
is it the type of thing where you're
going to want to find a way to shoehorn
in that memory
from you know when they were 8 years old
into the scene
because you did the work so i think it's
it's a very
interesting sort of dichotomy of
how much is too much research what you
need don't over research and and make
sure that you're
actually getting those pages written
why are limitations on film sets
actually a good thing in your mind
because that
is what brings out creativity having
limitations on a film set
brings out creativity because when
you're
sort of stuck by these boxes whether
they're financial
or you know location-based or time-based
the best stuff really really comes out
of you
like you're able to think of things that
maybe you wouldn't have you know if you
had all the resources in the world
it can be over indulgent but when you
don't have any resources then you really
have to get crafty
and that's when the most and the purest
creativity comes out
and what i've found is that things are
much better when there are rules and
sort of borders
that you have to sort of work your way
around versus you can do anything
so you know you end up you know
potentially with nothing
that's true like maybe a cool backdrop
but then the story suffers
with broken ceiling you had one location
um you had it for four days you had all
your actors there
you knew like you didn't have to really
change locations were there other
limitations
within that within that office building
where you were shooting
that really lent itself to the story uh
i
think you know we had a little bit of
free reign of that office which was
great it was
just the limitation of time
was something that everybody runs into
um but for us you know we had like a
monitor
sitting there going like like you have
to be out
by a certain time you know you can't go
over this
um so that was something that you know
kept us going because it's like
we only have this much time in the day
you know we're gonna shoot for maybe 10
12 hours but like that's it we can't
keep shooting we can't go over like we
don't have that luxury
so with the time constraint you know
that was very motivating and and helped
everybody and plus
you know uh the story itself just lended
itself
to that because i wanted them to feel
like they were in a high pressure
situation so the fact that we were in
reality in a high pressure situation
really really helped you know get that
feeling on the actors
because they're on a conference call on
a sunday mm-hmm and they all have to
kind of go and face each other
yeah interesting yeah and how many pages
did you do a day
um i think the most we ever did in one
day was about
60 pages oh wow which is insane
and unheard of if we did
like you know between 80 and 90 setups
which is crazy but again totally doable
because we didn't have to move lights
you know using the all-natural lighting
um but yeah like we we were definitely
cranking through and
getting it and you know it's it's a
tough thing to do
when you're in a conference room for the
majority of your running time
you just i remember thinking how do i
make sure that people aren't bored
because that's the most important thing
because it can be so easy so like
visually i have these four walls right
those are the parameters like
what can i do to really make this one
look into
look interesting but make sure that it
really gets across what the characters
are going through
visually which was a hard thing to do
but but something i think we were able
to accomplish
did you do a lot of close-ups then of
just like eye movement
or like how did you yeah it was a
variation of not using too much
you know close-ups but when it was
necessary using that using
movement when the moment or the scene
called for it um you know there's a
specific moment that i can recall
where you've got uh ken you know the
boss sitting in the center of the
conference room
and then you've got tyler and uh and
garrett on the sides and they're sort of
going back and forth you know like
sniping at each other
so it's like if you have three of them
right here how do i make this
dynamic and interesting and show the
interplay between the characters
so what i came up with is having the
camera throw
from character to character and sort of
a one take so
you know we would have tyler say
something and then we would whip pin it
over to garrett
who would say something we would go back
and then we would go to ken and then
back and forth
so you could go oh they are you know
volleying off of each other almost
playing a verbal tennis
you know so you see that and that would
play so much more different had i
decided to do just the standard you know
like
single shot here single shot there
cutting back and forth to really like
ground it in one shot and move it back
and forth gave it much more of a sense
of
energy and a connectedness that i don't
think
you know just standard sort of cunning
back and forth would have done
did the actors know that at one point
you would do 60 pages
in one day of your four-day shoot no no
of course not um but it's just what we
were able to do
which was great i let them know that we
were going to be shooting a lot and we
had to get a lot done
but i even i didn't think that we were
going to shoot that much like i didn't
plan
for like let's do 60 pages like that's
insane i was like okay let's
we got to get at least 20 maybe 30 you
know for four days
we'll stitch together 90 minutes but
but we were just in it you know and and
they were
down for it and they wanted to keep
going and
you know it was exciting because
everybody was sort of pushing
towards that same goal of like let's get
this done
and because you know the the fact that
they're all stuck in this room together
and sort of like at each other's throats
it's like it absolutely helped
that we were just barreling it through
it because it didn't give them
time to think or reflect back
on online readings or performances
like they were really in the moment
which is
what was necessary for it and i think we
got the best performances out of it
because of that constant sort of like
striving and pushing
when day four came toward the end of the
day how are those last few hours and
then when
when they finally said okay it's time
like how are you loading
the truck what's that like sure um there
were no trucks
didn't have money for trucks okay it was
a toyota camry let's
load it up into the car and do that and
like find some place to throw out trash
that was interesting um the fact that
you know at this location like we had to
bring trash bags
and we had to take the trash with us wow
so trying to figure out in los angeles
where
where can i legally throw away trash
was something that we had to do that i
had to do you know after each shooting
day so just
another thing that a director has to do
is drive around with trash in their back
seat and try to throw it out someplace
um but could you take it to the dump
no no we found like some open you know
trash
bins chucked it in you know
which out of the four days on broken
ceiling was the 60 page
60 pages that that was the second day
the second day was the one that we did
the 60 pages i think the first day we
did around
30 and then the second day we did around
around 60 or so um
and yeah it's funny because we did so
much stuff like that first weekend
and then i was able to go back and just
you know i had a full week
to sort of look at the footage and i
started editing right away
and i found certain things that we had
missed or that we didn't get or that you
know there was like a boom shadow in
some of the shots and like stuff that
on the day like we hadn't caught so it
was
it was super invaluable and i'm so glad
that we split it up into
two chunks because i was able to look at
everything and go okay like
we actually need to reshoot this and we
need you know a pickup of that and we
got to do this
um so when the next weekend came around
i had built in
you know into the shooting schedule all
of these things that we had to sort of
reshoot
which was an interesting challenge but
everybody you know sort of rose up to
that
but then on the the sort of final days
uh and the final day specifically
it was down to all of the uh the karen
kendrick stuff
you know for her character angela
because she there's a
thread through the movie where she's
sort of you know we see her on her own
which is very interesting and very fun
and cinematic because we got to venture
outside of the conference room
and sort of travel you know throughout
other parts of the office
and uh it was cool because everybody
else was sort of gone that day
it was actually i think it was father's
day or it was
one of the holidays where a couple of
crew members were like oh yeah i
couldn't
can't make it you know um i think we
lost our script supervisor or whatever
on on that day in one of our producers
but
it was all right because it was mostly
like non-dialogue based it was more
visual
so it was cool because we got to shoot
the final shot
of the movie as sort of the last thing
that we actually shot
so it was nice you know and it was
calming after all of that you know
long dialogue and work to sort of spend
a day
shooting non-dialogue based visual stuff
uh it was cool at the end of the day the
four
four days did a representative from the
building come up
and be like okay guys this is it we got
to wrap this up or
how does that work uh for that we had a
monitor that was kind of there the whole
time
um so yeah there wasn't a like you know
you guys got to wrap it up by that time
we knew
that like we have to go but it was cool
in that like the last day we didn't
shoot the full amount
um it was a little bit of a shorter day
so we left a little bit early and it was
still
you know it was still sunny out and the
sun was actually coming down you know
magic hour it was
it was pretty good and and it was very
emotional i remember it um
and this is something that for some
reason and maybe it's just the way that
i
handle you know being done with a shoot
but
um i remember you know going to my car
you know the car with a bunch of trash
bags in the trunk
and uh and and i drove home and i sat
there in the garage and i took about
i don't know maybe five ten minutes and
i just sort of like
started crying um like happy
tears happy that we had done it sort of
relieved that we had done it
but just so grateful that everybody
had jumped in to do this crazy thing
shooting a feature film in four days
shooting 60 pages in one day like that's
insane
but everybody hopped on board and they
did it and just like it was all the
emotions of like gratitude and
thankfulness that came out
and yeah it was it was a great feeling
and again one of those feelings that
that i love to have and that's why i'm
still you know making films what makes a
good story to you
something that uh grabs you
almost immediately something that
makes you think makes you feel more
importantly
um things that you know if it has
elements that you don't expect
it can surprise you um just take you
through the gamut of emotions you know
laugh cry
all of that that's
what i think a good story is something
that really
makes you feel you know
i always ask people what their favorite
movie was as a kid but actually
maybe more in your 20s when you were
older when you were sort of
trying to figure out what you wanted
sure was there a movie that you saw
where you were like oh
wow this is really what i want to do
yeah
there have been a few i have like the
sort of my my list
of five that really impacted me
you know as i was growing up i think
from a young age it was batman returns
uh because that and i look back at that
movie and i'm sort of
amazed by it it's so
weird and subversive and like strangely
violent for a kid's movie and like sexy
and it's one of those things
and the aesthetic that tim burton had
and was just like amazing and it's
something that like
definitely seated deep inside of myself
of like
this is you know what i like nowadays in
films um
the matrix when i saw that at 16 it
absolutely blew my mind um
it really made me rethink the world and
as a 16 year old like seeing that
uh it's just forever like altered me
like
the fact that that movie can alter you
as a person and change your brain and
change your trajectory in life
that is an immense power you know and
i'm so grateful for
the wachowskis like making that movie
because like who would i be
if i hadn't seen that who knows but
v for vendetta another one of those
films
that i absolutely love and has great
social commentary
the kill bills volume one and two
um definitely my favorite of tarantino's
um i i spent so many years
shooting films and like trying to mimic
his style and his inserts and all that
stuff
um just because they impacted me so much
and uh the departed
i think is tremendous and
it's an amazing example of a script
that you read and you're like okay this
is pretty good and then you see the
movie and you're like
whoa like what happened
because it's so different and i read the
script after i
saw the movie and i was like how did
this script turn into that movie
and you know after sort of hearing you
know how scorsese talked about the
process of it
you go like oh wow like there was so
much improvisation
and so much sort of on the fly and
that's why the editing is like so
kinetic and
interesting and like how it's built the
way it is
um is because they were so
improvisational the actors wanted to do
things and like you know martin just
like went with it and it
still you know came out with this
cohesive amazing story
which i think is just an absolute
mastery
um and then yeah children of men
on that list and i don't know if i
mentioned it already but in bruges
in bruges is just it just
hits me right in like the umami
of a movie you know what i mean like it
it hits me on such a
deep level um just because of like
the pain of the characters and the the
comedy in it and
the dialogue is is just fantastic and
the action in it and just everything
like
when when you find movies that like
speak to you which is is
sort of rare and it feels like it was
kind of a part of you
you know like whiplash is one of those
movies where it's like
that's a movie where i'm like it gets me
mad because i was like ah
i wanted to i wanted to tell that i
didn't know that that was inside of me
but it's so
it's so exciting that that movie exists
because it you know feels like
a part of me um yeah those
those are the ones that really have sort
of like impacted me and like
set up what i love about film and the
things that i
try to strive for and not to mimic them
but to sort of make
you know things that are true to me that
people you know
in the future may look at and go that
movie sort of changed my life like that
would be the highest compliment like i
can give
the wachowskis for the matrix for
changing my life if somebody
you know would say that about one of my
films like
there is no higher compliment than that
if i'm
understanding you correctly then you
were saying because i think i felt this
too like
seeing a movie and being so overtaken by
it that you were
upset that you didn't get to make it
because it i i felt that too
yeah and it's not it's not like an envy
thing it's just this is so much like i
get this movie how could someone else
get this to you know like i get it
it's you almost can't put it into words
exactly right and you're like speechless
after the film and you're sitting in the
theater and you're like
can everyone just go because i just need
a moment this is like right
and you know and then you see someone
else is doing the same thing you're like
wait a minute this is really affecting
people and it's that connection
that you don't know that you're gonna
have when you set out to make a film you
know
like the director couldn't have known
that that movie was gonna affect me the
way it did but
that's the sort of like alchemy and
magic of it that
it can do that these stories these
movies can do that to people and it's
it's amazing we've kind of had a running
theme here in the last few weeks of
filmmakers just saying briefly a movie
they saw when they were probably too
young to see it
is there a fun example of that yeah
totally uh
i think i was definitely in kindergarten
and i
saw friday the 13th one of those
the one where he eats the cockroach i
remember that completely because i
remember shutting my eyes and going like
ah
like it's way too young to be seeing
that and then
i think around the same time period was
terminator 2.
that one
[Laughter]
should not have you know seen that when
he starts like
you know cutting the arm and like
revealing the stuff it was like oh my
god and it's so violent but so good
like the fact that you can watch a movie
that good
at a young age even though you shouldn't
be is like you should
you should watch it because it's just
that good even though it's not
appropriate
was that the babysitter that was playing
it i know he was friends
friends and parents who were awake or
whatever you know like no babysitter's
like let's
put this vhs in and watch it